[Música]
en invierno es un terreno hostil que
recorre la frontera con suiza la región
del sur en francia tierra salvaje y
abierta un paraíso para los esquiadores
de fondo y los caminantes con raquetas
de nieve
es hermoso tan hermoso
sólo unos pocos intrépidos vienen aquí
para intentar la causa de hacer una ruta
de senderismo esquí de más de 100
kilómetros esto es lo que me gusta del
surf a los paisajes abiertos bordeados
de bosques la actividad agrícola que se
percibe en los prados los pastos y las
granjas me encanta todo eso me siento
como un pez en el agua
la ruta permite a los esquiadores
descubrir lugares fuera de los circuitos
habituales de la región como mus el
pueblo más frío de francia
en condiciones de iniciar
a lo largo del camino los excursionistas
y esquiadores descubren estas casas
típicas del yoga están cubiertas con una
capa de texas de madera llamada está
visión una técnica ancestral y el
orgullo de la población local como
lógico travel que ha hecho de ella su
profesión hace e instala está visión
protege los edificios de la lluvia
protege las paredes de la humedad ya que
una pared humedad hace que la casa se
sienta fría así se mantienen las paredes
agradables y secas usach este
revestimiento tiene más de un siglo de
antigüedad la lluvia lo ha vuelto gris y
el frío y el viento lo han carcomido así
que es hora de cambiar pero eso no es un
problema porque la mitad del cura está
cubierta de bosques
esto es más pesado de lo que parece
loi que es uno de los últimos
fabricantes de está visión del yoga hoy
su cabeza de hacha ha encontrado oro un
abeto de altura de 200 años o la de
deseos anillos son de 2 milímetros 3
milímetros como máximo los abetos crecen
muy lentamente eso es lo que les da su
calidad y durabilidad cuanto más
apretados está en los anillos más dura
será la madera eso es lo que dicen los
ancianos no se puede aprender este
oficio en la escuela lógica aprendió de
un anciano
y lo bueno de este trabajo es que en
invierno estoy resguardado haciendo los
está billones y en verano cuando hace
buen tiempo y estoy al aire libre
colocando lo que hice en invierno
durante la noche nuestros esquiadores se
alojan en uno de los 150 refugios que
bordean la gran traverse de yoga una
oportunidad de oro para degustar algunas
de las especialidades de la región
no es exactamente comida ligera pero
ponerse el reto de subir un macizo
escarpado tampoco es algo que se toma a
la ligera así que necesitamos contrapeso
para mantenernos en marcha y que los
esquís se adquieran el camino
el conte es el queso emblemático del
yoga en esta antigua fortaleza del
ejército los queseros han sustituido a
los soldados pero el sitio abierto a los
visitantes ha conservado su carácter
excepcional
fue idea de napoleón la hizo construir
para tres mil quinientos hombres y dos
mil caballos y debía ser capaz de
resistir una serie de un año por eso hay
decenas de kilómetros de galerías y
cientos de bóvedas de almacenamiento
excepción tened esto está en nuestra
mente
[Música]
en la actualidad estas bóvedas con
paredes de roca protegen 140.000 quesos
con té y proporcionan condiciones
ideales de maduración todos reciben una
atención personalizada en primer lugar
se salan las superficies la sal extrae
el agua
a continuación se cepilla cada queso
tres veces por semana así es como se
forma la corteza ahora sólo necesitan
tiempo para que los sabores se
desarrollen el maestro quesero los
evalúa de oído
qué estás comprobando
ejecute estoy escuchando lo que me dice
cada queso si uno sabe escuchar el queso
le dice muchas cosas se puede escuchar
si la pasta tiene buena consistencia
este está bueno y firme una verdadera
delicia en toda la dulzura de un queso
más que tú
de vuelta al exterior el tiempo no es el
mejor para los esquiadores es uno de los
últimos descensos de sus vacaciones así
que están aprovechando al máximo pero el
yoga nos revela todos sus secretos en
invierno así que será necesario volver
en verano cuando sus excepcionales
paisajes tienen un aspecto muy muy
diferente